Have you been wondering why you can't sit still and study?
Do you always fall asleep or get distracted by other things?
Well, don't worry because we all do it.
But there are ways to avoid slacking off while studying.
And we will show you how to do that in this video.
First, don't spend too many hours studying straight.
Your mind will become congested and everything will just look boring.
Take regular breaks after each hour or after each task is completed.
Put away distractions like your mobile phone or magazines.
Just try to focus on one thing at a time.
Keep your study environment clean and bright.
Your mind will absorb more information this way.
Also, keep your notes and folders organized.
That way, you wouldn't have to waste your time finding things.
And remember to eat and drink well to give your brain some energy.
Regular walks to the cafeteria or to your kitchen might also help your brain relax.
Another distraction is the environment.
If there are too many people around or if it is too noisy, move to a different place.
Remember to keep track of the time and take your regular breaks.
That way, you will avoid falling asleep or slacking off to do other unproductive things.